all right we're going to look at a
pretty entertaining but also disturbing
clip today this is a clip of republican
senator tommy tuberville he participated
in a national security senate hearing
and it's on the one hand hilarious
because the guy can't put together a
coherent question or sentence throughout
uh his
his opportunity to ask questions at the
same time it's really disturbing because
this is who the people of alabama
selected to send to the senate so it's
hilarious and it's disturbing check this
out the guy can't ask one question that
makes any sense uh good morning
uh director haynes
in your best assessment does russia
intelligence closely monitor our
secretary of defense
i think russian intelligence tries very
closely to monitor all of our senior
leaders
okay so that so far we're okay does
russia monitor our leaders fine now look
at where this goes so you believe that
noted that when he or
when he or
said that russia weakens
what and that the u.s will move heaven
and earth to arm ukraine
uh
do you believe that's right he should
say that
yes i i think secretary clinton do you
believe russia blames the u.s
intelligence community for helping
ukraine shoot down a russian plane
carrying hundreds of people
i'm sorry sir can you repeat the
question do you believe russia blames us
our intelligence agency for ukraine
shooting down a plane with hundreds of
troops on board
do you think russia blames us for that
which plane are you thinking of
there was a plane recently that was shot
down russian plane that a hundred troops
you believe that they blame our
intelligence agency for that
i i don't know sir okay uh do you
believe that uh russia blames our u.s
intelligence for sinking uh
uh their flagship uh moskova uh do you
think they blame us for that i don't
know sir we haven't seen any director to
what extent do you accept that russia
believes do you excess i think he means
a set i mean it's i'd i gen if if he if
this guy has a reading disability then
okay but as far as i knew he didn't
and he's just struggling to make sense
with english words and trying to put
them together
it is a war
with the west in the united states you
think that they believe you excess it is
at war they're at war with us
russia
has historically believed that they are
in a conflict in effect with nato and
the united states on a variety of issues
including in cyber and so on so you
believe that they're fighting us
that they're fighting us as well as
they're fighting ukraine correct
in a sense
their perception yeah yeah because we're
arming them and we're talking okay
general barrier does united states or
ukraine have air superiority over the
war zone which one has air support
superiority i would i would call it uh
senator i would call that an air an
error
standoff right now i mean the russians
can can fly tactical aircraft over the
line
i
i guess maybe
what he was getting into the direction
of is that
it's dangerous in ukraine like okay so
i'm gonna be as charitable as i can here
about what tommy tuberville was trying
to make uh uh evident here
he was trying to make the case that
listen
even if we don't consider that we are at
war with russia
russia does see themselves as being in a
conflict with the united states
and
we as the united states don't actually
have control of the airspace over
ukraine
so
us officials are shouldn't go to ukraine
because it's dangerous or something like
i'm trying to make sense out of nonsense
here uh but what is clear is that our
country is in pretty serious trouble
this is one out of 100 senators
this is not like oh you know
it's just everybody gets to speak at a
school board meeting and it's just a
random person from the community who
doesn't know anything about
anything
this is one of 100 senators random
poli-sci students would have better and
more coherent questions than tommy
tuberville but this is the guy that
alabama republicans said we want we want
to send him to the senate we get two of
the hundred senators
here's the guy that we want to send
we're in trouble as a country folks
we're in trouble as a country and it is
looking very very ugly
i love documentaries and i bet many of
you do as well and for documentaries i
go to curiositystream one of our
sponsors it's an app for your phone
tablet tv like netflix or hulu except
curiositystream has a way better
selection of documentaries because
curiosity stream only has documentaries
that's what they specialize in if you
are looking for the new award-winning
documentary they have it if you're
looking for classic documentaries they
have those they have a ton of great
original content always adding more to
the catalog i just watched
zenith which is about the latest
advancements in space travel a topic i'm
super interested in but there's
documentaries about just about every
topic imaginable i've been a curiosity
stream subscriber for several years now
it's my favorite app on my roku
and the best part of curiosity stream
it's 15 bucks a year
at curiositystream.com
pacman and the link is down below